Welcome Back to the Future chain Design
This is PJ today I would like to talk
about this 3D model tutorial for jewelry
care design on this Crown pendants are
you ready let's get started
to making this pendant we could have on
the bottom with the same under bezel
setting like the one that we have on the
top but I actually wanted them to be
solid piece so that way it will be more
durable when my chin is keep rubbing
there on the body and so that's starting
from the scratch I'm going to bring in
this Stone first and then you can
download the stone file at the
description below sign up for the news
later and there will be a link for you
to download this file now once you get
your stone file you can size the stone
into whatever size that you want in this
case I have 1.5 millimeter after we do
that we need to Define it how big this
pendant is going to be I'm going to type
it zero here and I'm going to type it
for the diameter for 10 millimeter and
for something like this you can make it
bigger or smaller but I'm just simply
going to move this one up here that will
be our first stone I will also like the
stone to be online so that's is using
align centers and just type it zero
there so it's right in the middle now we
have this we need to creating the piece
behind the stone let me go ahead to
bring the stone more close to here and
simply we just going to draw a rectangle
with The Arc corner so I'm going to left
click here and we can draw any size as
soon as this is wider than the stone and
for the thickness I don't need it to be
too thick it will be too heavy so
something around here it should be fine
and bring in a little bit to get the
radius all right so I want a stone to be
positioned sitting right on top so the
girdle you want them to be aligned with
this area right here so the girdle is
sitting on the faces right there okay so
now we got we can take a look on it and
see if every position is correct if that
look correct to you I'm going to pick up
this one and just using the surface
First Tool we have revolve we want to
snapping into the zero right here for
360 Degree
so then we'll get more like a ring band
over there okay so now I'm looking at it
I feel like this guy I forgot to align
so let's go ahead pick up the under
Right View and I want to align
horizontal Center and just type it zero
here so now it is it look at the line
all right the second things that we
wanted to do is we want to see how many
Stone do we needed for this one so let's
go ahead to using the polar array and I
want to snapping into the zero and
that's giving a guessing like I'm going
to get 16 here
and as you can see that this is a really
big space in between if you want to
share probably not gonna work so I'm
going to bump it up a little bit so
let's try 20. and then ideally you want
to get in between
for about 0.1 to 0.2 millimeter this one
it should be all right there so I'm just
going to use the 24 hour store size
right so once you have that I'm going to
draw a straight line really short line
right there and this is going to be our
prong and I'm going to use the pipe
command and we're gonna pipe in the size
roughly like this okay once you have
this one I want this going in between
and tilt it a little bit to follow the
direction on the surface and I want to
move this right in the middle so let's
come back to take a look here I'm going
to bring this one up and you want to
check on my perspective View and see if
they are right in the middle so let's go
ahead to bring up just a little bit all
right so if that one look okay we are
going to simply just mirror to the other
side because this is symmetrical just
type in zero here and using the mirror
command and then you can get something
like this all right now with this one we
need to make a bunch of them so we're
simply just going to use the polar array
snapping into the zero as a center and
let's do 20 of them the same like what
we had with the stone size so now we
have that first part is done you can
creating a cutter if you want to Simply
to do is draw a circle exactly the same
with the stone size or just tiny smaller
and then you can extrude it with the
Gumball first pick up the curve again
and you want to extrude it again now
when you extruded this one you want to
hold down the shift to bring in a little
bit and once you get this one you want
to extrude it one more time right so
that way you will get those three
surface and what you can do is to join
them once you join them you can use the
cap command to close it so then you will
have this is a cutting tool I'm going to
change them into other layer
so that way you will see they are there
all right so the way that you're going
to do it the same we're going to use the
polar array with exactly the same number
Center will be zero let's use 20 of them
and then we'll get something like this
now simply you just want to use the
Boolean different to cut a hole behind
the stone I highly recommend you do all
of you do the whole on each of the stone
the reason is it will be easier to clean
later on because humans tend to have a
lot of different grease on the body and
that will you know getting into behind
the stone will be really hard to clean
all right so if you have a hole behind
the stone it will look that it will be
much easier to clean at the same time
your rendering will look better alright
let's continue I want to come back to
the top view and in this top view I'm
going to draw another Circle snipping
into the zero and circle light
somewhere in the middle of this piece
all right and let's go ahead to turn off
the original layer so we can just deal
in with this one oops it's tilted that's
fine we're gonna come into the top view
in fact I'm going to delete it and let's
come back to the top view and we want to
do something like this right about in
the middle and let's open this to make
sure that's the line in fact doesn't
need to be a little bit bigger like this
okay so for this one what we like to do
is we want to separate them into the
section in this case I have 20 stone
there so I actually want to divide this
into the 10 section let's go into use
the Divide
comment and with the Y command I want to
divide them into the 10 section so once
you're done then you'll have all those
points right and we just need to have
two of the point as an example so those
two points is going to act in my cutting
tool and it's going to cutting the rest
of it all right so that is the curve
that we are looking for rest of it we
can just delete it all right so this is
the curve that we have and we want to
create some sort of Arc there so what I
like to do is I'm going to rebuild this
curve and we want to rebuild into the
degrees three and we just need to have
four point right there and that is allow
us to have some point to to play around
so I'm going to pick up this one and
this one and just bringing up something
like this so that will be a proper size
for it let's go ahead to turn on our
original button of the crown and I'm
going to bring this one up all right
depends on what kind of shape that you
like you can actually bring up more if
you want to just turn on the control
point and then you can continue to bring
up or on the bottom those two you can
actually bring them wider by dragging
the control Point make them a bit wider
all right so what we can do with this
one we can simply just pipe it so let's
go ahead to pipe it and I like to have
something about
this size on both end and right in the
middle I want to add one there so make
sure your quadrant is on on the old snap
and I want something a bit bigger there
and then I will get something like this
now it looks like a smiling face that's
good make sure it's in the correct
position and I also wanted to have this
to be polar array so since we divided by
10 it's making more sense we using the
same number let's go ahead at the top
view type a zero here
and I wanted to number to set it up for
10.
and that's how we get this piece right
here now you can gem a stone right in
the middle if you want to or you can
just make another one up there I'm going
to copy the stone that I have right here
with one of the prong so I'm just going
to pick up this Stone
and pick up the prong
and I'm going to move them up like here
all right so for the stone simply I'm
just going to draw a tube snapping into
the vertex first and you don't have to
snapping anywhere and but you want to
get it under bezels just slightly
smaller than the stone size as long as
you can cover the coolant that will be
fine I think this is a little bit too
wide so let's go ahead to uh 1D scale it
all right so now I have that piece right
there in fact this is already tilted I
probably don't want to use that so let's
draw another one we wanted to have a
straight line right here and with this
one we just simply wanted to pipe it so
let's go ahead to use the pipe command
for something about this big all right
so now we have this one let me align
them first a lot of time if you don't
lie they just don't look correct and we
want to get into something like this
maybe a little bit longer alright so
let's take a look on this one let's
bring this one up to where it should be
somewhere there and I also like to trim
the bottle now so let me go ahead to use
to draw a line close to the bottom right
here and use that line to or a curve to
trim off this bottom right there all
right so we want to cap it first to
close our Bottom now at the front view
I'm going to use the polar array and I'm
going to snapping into the vertex I want
it to have number four which is a four
prong there and double make sure
everything is touching so you have a
good print there all right and if this
look right to you and I'm going to have
them grouped together all right so we're
going to use the rotate tool snapping
into the zero holding the shift click on
the bottom of the stone the number we
wanted to rotate it is 360 divided by
20.
and you don't have to do the calculation
the Rhino will do that for you all right
so double make sure they are sitting
into the right place and see if they
need to come out a little bit or not
right now once you have the correct
position that you liked you can click on
this one again we repeating using this
command for Polar array and snapping
into the zero and we wanted to have 10
of them so that's how we can get this
Crown pendant once you put the chin on
it that will be a nice really nice
little pendant to wear I hope you enjoy
the video if you're interested in other
type of setting I do have a stone
setting course on my website welcome to
check out the course and let me know if
you have other questions thank you for
watching and I'll see you next
[Music]
foreign